à chacun sa posture sa méthode et ses
plantés sèches en tout cas à l'ombre des
bambous dans le jardin de la
Bibliothèque départementale les lycéens
ont choisi le calme et la plénitude des
lieux pour se pencher sur les textes
philosophiques ou encore techniques du
baccalauréat 2015 ils seront 11340
candidats cette année à essayer de
décrocher le fameux sésame en attendant
on prend des notes on fait des fiches
bref on révise à fond j'ai beaucoup de
tentations chez moi et du coup j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à me concentrer
quand je suis quand je suis chez moi du
coup je trouve que c'est vraiment plus
agréable de pouvoir travailler en fait à
la bibliothèque pour pour être plus
concentré en fait j'habite juste à côté
c'est gratuit c'est calme ce moyen peut
des autres donc voilà ne pas se laisser
tenter par le monde moderne pas de
téléphone pas d'internet pas de télé la
Bibliothèque départementale offre un
cadre propice à la concentration c'est
plus calme et à moins de tentation
comme la télé par exemple j'ai trop de
tentations chez moi du coup bah je fais
comme l'année dernière je vais arriver
parce que j'aime bien le cadre et
j'arrive à me concentrer ici et puis il
y a ceux qui veulent avant tout
s'entourer de leurs amis pour partager
et changer leur connaissance un moyen de
se rassurer et de combler ses lacunes
déjà je trouve que l'environnement ici
est plus propice au révision et tout
parce que je suis chez moi je suis toute
seule il y a pas forcément la volonté en
fait de travailler et donc du coup ben
ici c'est le mieux chaque les amis on
fait des petits quizz des trucs ensemble
et puis voilà on a envie de travailler
c'est important d'être avec quelqu'un
non mais c'est mieux pour apprendre on
est ça peut on peut aller plus vite
comme ça
s'il y a une quelqu'un qui a pas compte
il y a pas bien compris les choses ben
l'autre elle explique enfin voilà on
s'entraide et oui bah c'est c'est un
cadrage c'est convivial et enfin c'est
tranquille en fait pour essayer de calme
du coup oui c'est mieux que qu'on est à
la maison révisé en bibliothèque
beaucoup d'étudiants font ce choix c'est
pour répondre à cette demande que la
Bibliothèque départementale a mis en
place des horaires adaptées mais
également une longue liste d'analents
pré gratuit sur place pour donner toutes
les clés pour la réussite de nos lycéens
pour leur permettre de travailler
davantage parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
que il y a une très très grosse demande
environ 15 jours à un mois avant les
examens de salle de travail de lieu
propice à la concentration c'est
pourquoi on a modifié nos horaires en
conséquence l'année dernière les
résultats qui sont arrivés jusqu'à nous
tendre et approuver que tout soit obtenu
leur bac maintenant j'ai pas de
statistiques précises mais en tout cas
il semble que ce soit plutôt bénéfique
100% de réussite au bac c'est le
résultat affiché par la Bibliothèque
départementale puisque tous ceux qui
sont passés par ces lieux en 2014 ont
obtenu leur diplôme outre que d'offrir
un cadre bienveillant la Bibliothèque
départementale porte bonheur le bonheur
un sujet de philosophie qui plairait à
plus dans lycée